[Música]
e se eu te disser que seu maior sonho
pode se tornar realidade
mas pra isso você teria que encarar de
frente os seus maiores medos e superar
cada limite que você acha que tem você
faria
eu fiz o sport apareceu muito cedo na
minha vida através do meu pai é
cardiologista que nadava e corria na
infância ele sempre foi uma grande
inspiração pra mim eu comecei a nadar
com seis anos e aos 12 anos eu fiz minha
primeira travessia em mar aberto
já na adolescência eu comecei a correr e
o sport foi me acompanhando ao longo da
vida em 2011
eu fui assistir pela primeira vez a um
ironman é uma prova de triatlo
o triatlo é um esporte em que três
esportes se tornam um como triatleta
você nada
pedala e corre e o ironman é considerado
a prova de triathlon de um dia mais
difícil do mundo como triatleta você vai
ter que nadar 3.8 quilômetros
pedalar 180 quilômetros e correr 42.2
quilômetros um seguido do outro
eu já tinha ouvido falar dessa prova eu
sabia que era algo punk mas só lá
entende de fato que era era um desafio
de resistência de 226 quilômetros a
serem completados em até 17 horas
eu me emocionei demais
a energia já repetia e ao mesmo tempo
que eu achei aquilo incrível parece uma
loucura ao impossível para meros mortais
mas uma das coisas que mais chamaram
atenção foi a quantidade de mulheres na
prova
dos quase 2.000 atletas sem eram
mulheres seja 5%
e foi naquele momento que eu disse um
dia eu vou fazer isso
só que não sabia nem como nem quando mas
o irão nem se tornou um sonho grande
cinco anos se passaram em 2016 eu
iniciei minha jornada de triatleta que o
cenário não tinha mudado muito
as mulheres ainda eram a minoria não
chegavam nem a 10% na prova
foi aí que eu sentir que eu podia
construir uma comunidade para ajudar as
mulheres a superarem as barreiras comum
enfrentado no esporte
e assim eu decidi compartilhar o meu
sonho e sua construção diária desde o
primeiro dia no triatlo até me tornar
homem e através do meu perfil instagram
eu comecei a compartilhar toda a rotina
de treinos superações e desafios através
da hashtag mais mulheres no triatlo
existem quatro distâncias de provas de
triatlo desde a sprint que a menor
distância até o ironman e à medida que a
distância aumenta o número de mulheres
tai
só para vocês terem noção até 1975 as
mulheres eram proibidas de correr a são
silvestre
uma das provas mais tradicionais de
corrida do brasil que já existia há 50
anos
mas por que por que os homens afirmavam
que o corpo feminino não tinha nem força
nem resistência para fazer uma prova
dessa quem não está muito familiarizado
a são silvestre é uma prova de corrida
de rua de 15 quilômetros
bem eu treinei em média quatro horas por
dia durante a semana e até oito horas
nos finais de semana todos os dias e
muitas vezes eu não consegui acompanhar
meu grupo que era predominantemente
masculino
então chegava a pedalar de 100
17 horas sozinha na br 101 no inverno eu
precisei usar máscara de esqui de tanto
frio que fazia no pedal da madrugada
eu levei quase seis meses para conseguir
beber água enquanto pedalava de tanto
medo que eu tinha de cair tirar a mão do
guidão pegar a garrafinha em alta
velocidade e foram muitos tombos
principalmente por causa dos a partilha
na bike de contra-relógio nosso técnica
grudado no pedal e toda vez que você
para bike esquece de explicar você cai
mas por mais distante que em alguns
momentos parecesse eu acreditava que eu
era capaz de cumprir os 226 quilômetros
do ironman e muito mais do que um
desafio
encarei como uma jornada de
autoconhecimento e realização pessoal
treinar para manter o corpo forte mas
mais importante que isso manter a mente
forte porque o corpo só faz o que a
mente acredita
e quando a gente se supera de uma
maneira extraordinária a gente quebra
barreiras e você pensa se eu conseguir
fazer isso eu posso fazer qualquer coisa
mas não foi só isso
eu também tive barreiras sociais para
superar as mulheres são uma espécie rara
nesse ambiente brutal e é fácil entender
por que essa prova se chamar homem é um
mundo de homens lá fora e é triste que
as mulheres sejam tão sub representadas
no esporte que tanto cresce é preciso
coragem para fazer algo assim mas muito
mais coragem se você é uma mulher e pode
ser até intimidador para as mulheres
incluir esse esporte em suas rotinas
elas perguntam onde vou arranjar tempo
para fazer isso como que elas vão
aprender sobre todos os equipamentos do
universo do teatro e se elas não ser
capazes de superar seus maiores medos
como nadar em águas abertas
a intimidação existe
e ela pode ser paralisante mas o que
queria fazer
implorar para que os outros me
aceitassem não eu fiz o que eu podia eu
ignorei as piadas e os olhares
desconfiados e continuei treinando
muitas mulheres foram ensinadas a
conectar o exercício físico a aparência
mas o real benefício de treinar para o
ironman é aprender o quão forte você é e
descobrir que você é dona do seu team
eu acredito no empoderamento feminino
através do triatlo porque quando as
mulheres percebem que elas podem
alcançar no esporte
elas começam a ultrapassar fronteiras em
todas as áreas de sua vida
eu quero que as mulheres saibam que elas
podem ser e fazer o que quiserem e que
muitas vezes a gente vai seguir sentir
sozinha ea jornada pode ser até
assustadora mas valerá a pena
e aos poucos você compreende que não
precisa ser a melhor para inspirar um
dos exemplos mais marcantes para mim o
mais mulheres no triathlon é o caso de
uma das melhores triatletas amadoras
hoje no brasil que acompanhava o projeto
e compartilhava comigo suas dúvidas e
seus anseios bem no início da sua
jornada no triatlo quando ela ganhou uma
bicicleta do irmão e hoje é referência
do esporte no brasil e nos representa em
campeonatos mundiais
esse é o poder de uma comunidade
até agora são quase 10 mil
compartilhamentos da hashtag mais
mulheres no triatlo e mulheres do brasil
inteiro estão se conectando através do
esporte
no triathlon cada um tem sua trajetória
e suas vitórias pessoais e todos são
campeões
para mim foram 699 dias
desde que iniciei no triatlo até me
tornar homem e todas as vezes que você
cruza a linha de chegada
o locutor de parabéns agora você é um
ironman
mas eu não sou um homem de ferro
eu sou uma mulher de ferro e todas nós
somos a questão é o que te impede hoje
de se conectar a isso
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]